je suis franco manitobain en dehors de
la boîte quand je suis à l'extérieur du
manitoba je suis franco manitobain quand
je suis à l'intérieur du manitoba fait
ces menaces
moi personnellement dans ma vie je me
sentais juger quand j'ai déménagé unitec
de fêtes du village à envisager un
accent de fernie et comptait au à la
hauteur du français des gens ou à
l'urbain à mon vocabulaire quand même
été opéré et était plutôt l'accent qui
dérangeait les autres donnent passé en
10e année geo
j'ai fait un voyage puis à carreaux lieu
puis j'ai rencontré des québécois tout
souhaité me corriger la façon que je
parle là pis je sentais genre jugement
en ce moment là un peu plus jeune que
tout manque à mon école avait fait un
voyage au québec
déjà qu elle y parle notre examen
souhaitées francophonie demandait
c'était une première
l'acsa je pense que moi je le porte en
tout cas comme un peu un badge d'honneur
ça définit d'un peu de juin où c'était
un peu une saveur douce bien mais c'est
sûr que quand c'est accompagné de deux
jugements négatifs d'autrui c'est là que
ça devient pressant manger nam était un
peu insultant
je crois qu'ils aussi parce qu'on essaye
toujours de bâtir notre francophonie à
l'ouest
tu as ton minoritaire on veut agrandir
notre espace francophone
mais quand les jeunes qui ont parti vert
depuis que l'immersion en actant à
anglophones qui parle en français quand
même a souvent ils vont être jugés puis
c'est pas la meilleure façon de
démystifier jeunes de revenir
s'installer de notre côté de la rivière
comme on veut je pense qu'il ya un
certain apprentissage qui se fait au fur
et à mesure qu'on corman crédit sans
accent qu'une différence entre la
manière dont on parle et la qualité vaut
kabila sais pas si vous avez lu le livre
pour sûr de france d'escaladé 6 du chiac
et oui ça a apporté beaucoup beaucoup de
critiques
parce que c'est vraiment se taisent ils
différents vocabulaire mais ça vient
aussi avec la fsa et une discussion qui
se fait est ce que on devrait encourager
ou est ce qu'on devrait plutôt
encourager
tu es un vocabulaire donc plus qu'un
accent radio canada donc je viens dit je
pense qu une différence claire et nette
entre la qualité du vocabulaire et
l'accent et je pense que quand on est
plus jeune quand on est moins exposé des
différents axa se confond plus
facilement ça